thanks everybody I'm Nicholas be with
reason and this is our discussion about
libertarian populism and its discontents
and we have with us Tim Carney of the
washington examiner ben domenech of the
transom and of real clear politics and
Heartland Institute and Jesse Walker
also of reason and the author of the
forthcoming book the United States of
paranoia definitely give that a look
what we're going to talk about today for
about 30 minutes the panel will discuss
libertarian populism what is it why is
it perceived with such interest and such
hostility there was a piece today at
salon recently attacking I you know
putting a giving on r and a pitchfork
doesn't make her a populist or possibly
a libertarian whatever and what its
prospects are then we'll open it up some
questions for the audience I want to
thank reason TV for filming this as well
so let's get started with some
definitions real quick Tim why don't you
give us the thumbnail sketch of what
libertarian populism is in many ways at
a column at Washington Examiner almost a
year ago about 10 months ago you kind of
outlined an idea populist libertarianism
what did you mean by that so it was
after the election and or also after
romney's 47% comments it just really
struck me was Romney thought the problem
here is we can never get working class
or poor people to vote for us because we
believe in free markets and I realize
that Romney was buying into the very
idea that the liberals and lay out an
idea that if you're getting a direct
payment from the government or if you're
on welfare or but for him it was even he
was conflating the people who weren't
paying high tax rates with EP or people
who weren't paying income tax with
people who were getting a handout and so
that's when I sort of realized Romney's
whole play was for kind of the white
bread upper middle class people he
thought if you're successful you need to
be a Republican but then when I was out
the in the field in Ohio is like way
deciding if these people are successful
why are they going to turn against Obama
if they've had a good for years and then
you look at the economy and the numbers
that Obama himself sites like the middle
class
to stagnate it the working class has
stagnated the corporate profits are at
record high and then you realize
regulations entrench the big businesses
bailouts favor the big businesses small
businesses can try small businesses are
the ones that employ people and so in
short the game is rigged in America
government is one doing the rigging and
it's rigged in favor of the
well-connected the big and the wealthy
okay so that's the populists angle is
that you're kind of not quite as bad as
those of you have read the sound and the
fury will remember Jason Compson's
attack on Wall Street but it's banksters
who are in cahoots they're taking the
acela between new york and DC writing
the rules to keep them themselves in
riches and other people are getting
screwed and what's different about this
populism is that you're calling for
actual free-market reforms it's a way to
unring the system is to get government
out of it okay I've been talked a little
bit about your take or libertarian
popular well first off let me say thank
you so much for hosting this and I have
to say if nothing else comes out of the
conversation about libertarian populism
then Nick's fantastic excoriation of
Paul Krugman then I think it was still
worth it I definitely I rushed to say
that was merely an excuse to talk about
how he doesn't bother reading the people
that he criticizes which is a you know
an aspirational position for all of well
I needed a cigarette afterwards so thank
you the thing the thing that I think is
sort of interesting about libertarian
populism is I think it's been sort of a
long time coming and I think it's more
about culture than it is about sort of
electoral politics I think that the the
fusion 'used sort of agreement that that
Frank Meyer put forward was something
that really led to success on the right
for the course of several generations
for a number of reasons and it started
with a a common commonly-held vision of
what a life well-lived looked like
essentially that you would come out of
high school or college you would get
married you would have kids you would
buy a house you would buy a car you
would live in the suburbs they would go
to a good school etc etc all of these
different things had in effect in terms
of driving you towards at least small C
conservatism or limited government in a
number of different ways you started
carrying about not just property taxes
but you maybe had an interaction with
the teachers at your school that made
you think differently about
public education you started caring
about what was on TV you started caring
about the future of the world that you
were living in and caring about the
Soviet Union in that context and the
danger that it represented all of these
different things bound together a cohort
of individuals across the country who
had a certain vision of what a life
well-lived looked like what we've seen
in the wake of the downfall of the
Soviet Union and the Berlin Wall coming
down is that essentially the Republican
Party as a whole of course is only one
the popular vote in a presidential
election once since then and they did so
in the one election where they had a
stand-in for the now absent USSR in the
form of the threat of Islamic terrorism
in fact what we've seen is a complete
change in the way that Americans view
the life well-lived we've seen a
delaying of marriage a delaying of
childbirth we've seen situations where
now many of the people in this room you
you're going to have more jobs by the
time that you're 30 then your
grandparents had their entire lives
you're going to move all over the place
as opposed to staying near home because
of this you have different priorities
different policy priorities and you're
threatened by different things in terms
of the encroachment of big government
and big business the sorts of things
that Tim was talking about what I think
that we're seeing here is the rise of a
new era of individualism in America and
I think with that comes the
prioritization of individual liberty and
a rejection on the part of many of the
people who formally endorsed
compassionate conservatism a lot of
christian evangelicals who sort of were
were engaging in this do-gooder
paternalism are now turning against that
and reconsidering it so are you saying
though that I mean this new rise of
individualism is this a more inclusive
ideal where if you're gay if you're
black if you're living an alternative
lifestyle if you know Rand Paul talked a
while ago about how the Republican Party
if it's going to win has to include
people who have tattoos who have
ponytails who have black nail polish
stuff like that I think it is more
tolerant and I think that there are a
lot of particularly i would say
evangelical christians who are are
judging and judging harshly the sort of
santorum ask approaches that they may
have adopted in the past instead
realizing that religious liberty
individual liberty the liberty of
families to raise their children in the
way that they see fit is something that
has to be prioritized in the kind of
circumstance that we exist
yeah that the four that the idea of
trying to use civil law to like advanced
church teachings is something that has
backfired and said what the fight in
Washington is about is making it keeping
it legal for us to live as Christians
that's part of it from the sort of
social you and before we get to Jesse
will give us a kind of perspective on
populism as well as a libertarianism in
that you guys each would confine
yourselves more as conservatives and as
libertarians right you know I've always
considered myself a Christian
libertarian in a sort of small you know
rural sense in the I like home schoolers
I like raw milk and I like you know sort
of people being left alone with their
guns on their farms and so that's sort
of the way that I view I'm a libertarian
from nine to five and then I get home
and I'm a conservative I feel sorry for
your wife and kids but all of you know
all of the wives and all you know Jesse
talk a little bit about when you when
you hear this type of stuff how are you
seeing that as it plays out in a kind of
longer tradition of populism in America
which generally not exclusively but
generally comes from the left probably
and is more collectivist by definition
than individualist yeah I'm populism is
one of those words that people use in so
many different ways that it starts to
lose meaning and yet it has meaning I
there's a reason why people reach for
that word and I've always kind of liked
the word and a lot of it also I mean
that Michael in peace you mentioned I
starts quoting the populists party
platform of the 1890s which is often
it's a good place to start but it kind
of neglects the way in which even the
populist party was a sort of odd big
tent which had people ranging from like
hamlin garland who was a big herbert
spencer fan and about eighty percent
libertarian though he's into some things
like the georgia slant x as well all the
way out to people were like followers of
Edward Bellamy and wanted the state to
run everything so there's I from the
beginning populism has meant all kinds
of different things um when useful
distinction Lawrence Goodwin who wrote a
book called Democratic promise which was
a history of the populist party he wrote
in sort of the new left period and it's
drenched in that whole ambiance and it's
been supplanted as scholarship in a lot
of
it's buddy made an interesting
distinction in it between what he called
authentic populism and shadow populism
authentic populism being this initial
movement of people of farmers who are
trying to form cooperatives and change
the laws in ways that would let their
what they were building thrive and the
shadow populace being the people who
sort of signed on with William Jennings
Bryan and the cyrillic gimmicky free
silver crusade and the Democratic Party
and what a good one called hierarchical
politics and like I said that that's
really a simplification of the populist
party but it's an interesting
distinction to draw when you're talking
about populism since then since it cuts
across left right lines libertarian
authoritarian lines centralist
essentialist lines you've got on the one
hand this long tradition of sort of the
people will rule this idea of how do we
restore power to individuals and
communities which is very much not just
a matter of populist rhetoric but this
whole tradition of people who are not
professional political activists who
have volunteer driven groups that are
run entirely are almost entirely by
people who are it's it's part time they
have jobs elsewhere you know and then
there's this other idea of like the
people's Tribune the politician who
exploits that kind of anger I mean
youryour Huey Long's and so on who a
part of what comes to mind when you talk
about populism and who themselves then I
mean someone like Huey Long is like
concentrating power in order to attack
other power that's concentrated
elsewhere but now you can have someone
like Hillary Clinton or John Edwards
just sort of you say something kind of
rabble-rousing and people call you a
populist so how this comes around to
libertarian populism I mean what we can
say to make sense of that sort of
combination phrases is that if you're
talking about populism as a challenge to
concentrated power then libertarianism
matches it very well I think that and
when you talk about being a libertarian
populist if you mean that is sort of a
double-edged sword is that you're a
libertarian and that you're for greater
individual freedom and people being able
to make choices about their lives and
your populists in the sense of wanting
to break up this sort of nexus of state
and corporate power and also this sort
of your
cratic that mean I mean so much of the
what we think of as a free market
economy is actually just drenched in the
state whether it's banking insurance and
so on and I think there's a lot of
resentment against things like health
insurance companies and so on which can
be turned in a libertarian direction
when people like Tim's represent
libertarian reforms I think I'm just
glad that you brought up Huey Long you
know just to compare two lines together
obviously every man a king and that sort
of conversation I've always thought of
the Coolidge line as being kind of the
response to that you know the the
Constitution did not eliminate the
Divine Right of Kings that asserted the
Divine Right of all men and so because
of that I think you reach sort of a
populist ideal around the idea that the
threat doesn't just come from big
government you know conservatives have
been railing about big government for
forever but it comes also from other big
entities as well who have used
government to assert their own power
does this reduce libertarian populism
more to a kind of rhetoric though I mean
in some way it seems like an episode of
king of the hill where you know Hank
Hill goes from getting beaten up by the
local regulators to mega lo Mart where
there's a giant corporation that that
runs everything and is that mostly what
you guys are pushing back against I mean
is it bigness per se or does it matter
if it's big business versus big some
some of it is going to be rhetoric and a
positive rhetorical change and a
positive sort of attitude in other words
it's not just rhetoric it's not hating
people who have low income like Mitt
Romney hates people of low incomes don't
you think he hates him or he just he
they don't they don't exist he mean he
wrote them off and said they could not
be Republicans and so that's part of it
and then part of it is going to be
policy choices as jesse said we're in
this world where the the sort of initial
position is so mixed up with government
that what is the libertarian and Jesse
had it had blogged a little bit about my
idea that the banks are too big and they
need to be broken up and yesterday at
the examiner I put up a blog post I said
look a the banks are as big as they are
the mega banks in part because of
government privilege granted them
through implicit bailouts explicit
bailouts and regulation that acts as a
moat around them that was Jamie diamonds
exact word to describe dodd-frank it's a
moat be we know that they're being that
big
will lead to a bailout when they fail so
when you're a libertarian you come out
this and you say so we let them say this
big or now that we know there are these
subsidies maybe we tweak these subsidies
so as to prevent them from being that
big or limit their ability to access a
veil so there's a very quickly though
how do you how do you break up the banks
without creating of regulatory system
that is going to immediately be
recuperated into propping them yes yes
and so what I'd and also with a huge
political constituency for that I mean
tarp was never by most public opinion
surveys it was probably not widely
understood but it was never widely
popular and yet everybody knew it was
going to happen so the government the
banks have standing privileges from the
government some of which are explicit
and those can be tweaked so FDIC
insurance Fed lending window stuff there
are people who know more about bank
policy who have commented on this thomas
helena is one of them who said that
these privileges for the banks should be
curtailed and because the government is
both explicitly and implicitly the
insurer the government can go ahead and
set limits on their size so this is a
way of saying of acknowledging the
reality it might be impossible to get
rid of all the government privileges for
the banks so given that they exist we're
not going to regulate them or we're not
going to give some regulators from new
power we're just going to say you no
longer get access to this government
privilege above this size so it's taking
away some of the government privilege
and reducing the chance of a future
bailout so that's libertarian populism
going in a different direction from what
a libertarianism might go if it wasn't
aimed at taking on the large
beneficiaries of government privilege
isn't this really about sort of getting
rid of large institutions ability to
insulate themselves from risk and to
socialize that risk to the rest of us
and I think that I think in terms of
your question about policy an area where
this is obvious is a gas and groceries
based agenda we have more subsidies
mandates quotas and and tariffs in place
that affect the price of gas and
groceries than almost any other area of
the economy that impacts every single
Americans pocketbook when they go and
they shop for their favorites so
priorities you make sugar getting rid of
the sugar program up
priority because that would lower the
price of groceries if we got rid of that
subsidy now what about other kind of
specific policy recommendations that
come out of this so Tim you've written
about abolishing the the payroll tax
what happens you know I think everybody
would be like okay well that would be
great that would save me you know 12 and
a half percent or fourteen percent or
whatever of my paycheck but then on the
back side of that it's like okay that
also does that mean we get rid of Social
Security and Medicare and other
entitlements that seem to have a wide
you know a populist constituency and in
fact themselves were earlier emanations
of populist sentiment yeah and then so
you start by saying the Republican
priority has for years been lowering the
top income tax rates and I want to lower
all income tax rates I think it should
be a priority to get rid of the taxes
that affect your first dollar before
you're feeding your kid before I'm
paying for the diapers for my kids then
I'm paying into Medicare which by the
way is funding Warren Buffett's
healthcare so you you switch that
priority and you may be mean says some
of these entitlements if that makes
sense and then as far as do you want to
undo Medicare do you want to undo Social
Security ideally you do but this is a
sort of thing where libertarian populism
sets a priority and says no we're not
going to say we're gonna we're not going
to focus on taking I'm pushing grandma
off the cliff because there's a limited
amount of can afford her own parish
unless you can afford our own pair
there's a limited amount of political
capital and we're going to spend that on
the things that reduce government and
help the people the middle class in
context of the farm bill that was
recently pushed through was it a mistake
then to split the farm bill where you
have farm subsidies in one and food
stamps in another and to do farm
subsidies first and to back farm
subsidies as opposed to do food stamps
and actually allow food stamps I think
that Ross touted added correct in the
sense that this was sort of the worst of
both worlds situations the Republicans
once again showed their willingness to
defend AG subsidies to the hilt and in a
way that again you know enforces the
bigs and raises the prices for the rest
of us and I just want to point out you
know I think within this broader
conversation you know
talk I talked a little bit about the
rise of individualism the other thing
that we're seeing is the rise of
individual employment of self employment
within this economy there's enormous
regulatory burdens and biases within not
just the tax code but within the whole
of the state when it comes to licensing
and everything else that comes with that
that is biased enormously against that
kind of innovative work this is another
example of how libertarian populism is
about saying we want to have more
competition within a marketplace we want
to open this up and have more people
coming in and risking their own capital
in order to make gains and not have a
system that is biased in favor of the
people who can hire the lawyers and the
attorneys to help them navigate it
Joseph I I have a question for the two
spokespeople for libertarian populism
here which is that I'm really kind of
confused on one topic because there
seems to be a lot of slippage back and
forth and I just put together this wrong
reading list on libertarian populism for
hit-and-run yesterday and sometimes it's
specifically referring to this idea of
free market populism and other times
there seems to be this sort of three
legged stool I mean it's a combines the
anti corporatist economics with the new
sort of movement towards like an
anti-imperial foreign policy vision and
an interest in civil liberties at least
on the federal level that your serves
getting from people like Justin Amash
and so are we talking about a broad a
libertarian in-app things outside
economics or are we talking I'm you
brought up culture earlier but I mean
you didn't talk about a program in that
context well I actually do think that is
it's the whole I think this is the new
fusion ism I think this is the new
three-legged so then explain I think we
have a sense of the economic priorities
and policies where how does it play out
in things like foreign policy or
national security and then cultural
issues especially because you both have
identified yourselves as Christian
leaning I mean I assume that implies
that I know Tim you know being anti
abortion and what not sure how does this
play first off i think that i think that
the elites in Washington are becoming
more and more aware that the base has
learned as taken lessons from the last
ten years and that lesson is leading
them more towards anti interventionism
more towards skepticism of
of not just the power of the state I
think you see in the pew poll that came
out most recently about the complete
shift that you've seen and Tea Party
opinions of security programs and things
of that nature and then on the social
issues and all that tend to speak to
this as well I think there's a greater
understanding that a federalist approach
to these issues is a wiser one and that
what's more when it comes to these
issues it's again more about the liberty
of individuals and families to direct
their own path as opposed to sort of a
top-down shift along other lines so now
that I just want to comment on that
pupil the Tea Party big shift in civil
liberties was not from Bush to Obama it
was from 2010 to now still under Obama
most Republicans were rah-rah for spying
and that now basically simply a lot of
them stole our i mean the the Long
Knives are coming out for people like
Rand Paul from a GOP establishment that
is saying look this guy's McGovern two
point O Dave Weigel had a great articles
pointing out that this was Chrissy
playing to the GOP donor base so the the
GOP elites are not going to be on board
with a a foreign policy and and domestic
security libertarianism it will take a
fight against the elites something might
populism in order to advance this
libertarian national security and
foreign policy this argument has been
avoided for far too long by illegally to
pretended that this disagreement didn't
exist because they are afraid of the
fact that the people who largely send
their kids overseas to fight these wars
are skeptical about how does this play
out in terms of question like
immigration Ben you've written that part
of libertarian populism would be
building and enforcing a border fence
Tim you seem to kind of go back and
forth in terms of I mean you're not in
open borders enthusiasts so you know
this is another question where
immigration can be seen as you know
you're helping out the little guy by
keeping these you know hordes of people
coming who are you know going to cut
grass and do low-wage jobs for cheap or
it can also be that we're going to
create in order to maintain a you know
the integrity of the National citizenry
we're going to create a massive e-verify
system that every frickin American has
to go through where do you guys end up
with immigration you want to take
so yeah I mean I'm I'm totally a squish
meaning I have no idea what my policy
prescription would be on immigration
because obviously if somebody wants to
come to this country and live and work
we shouldn't stop them but the
immigration proposals put forward by
both parties that end up being
compromises end up being these basically
what business demands there's people
some people want open borders from
people like those borders for the
compromise is a Chamber of Commerce
proposal to only bring in people to work
specific jobs to fill these labor
shortages which is effectively big
business trying to use government policy
to drive down the cost of labor which is
not something I support but on the other
hand if people want to come here and
work and live what kind of populist
would I be if I said no you can't come
here so we're kind of libertarian would
I be so my ideal would be an open border
in no welfare state but the reality I
think that we face here is that that's
unlikely to happen I think within the
immigration bill leto as Tim said the
problem is that you're essentially have
this a crony estrangement where the
stakeholders at the table are the
chamber and la raza and they want to
divvy up the jobs and run the wage
scales from Washington I think that's
the wrong direction to go in and I think
that immigration is is a problem in the
long term but the bigger problem from my
perspective is you know you've heard the
trope about their jobs Americans won't
do that's not generally true except
there are jobs that Americans won't do
if the entitlement state pays them more
not to do it and that's what you see in
the population in Detroit and elsewhere
who have been sitting around on their
Duff's as opposed to moving to a place
where I don't know that there are that
many apples to pick with a Detroit
proper so that and more and more each
day and a kissy how does how does the
politics of immigration play out
traditionally or historically in
immigration or immigration debates and
populism well I mean one way it form
that populism takes is scapegoating
outsiders and immigrants are often the
outsiders to get scapegoated and so I
mean that's that's the ugly side of
populism I think and I think that I mean
I'm for open borders it's probably my
least popular political opinion so I
mean I'm I can't you know but I mean I
of course from the point of view of I I
think it actually makes a really good
point about these compromises in
who things like you verify and these
sorts of arrangements where people can
come and work here but they can't switch
jobs they can't start their own business
it's it's really like the wrong approach
to immigration reform but you know I
mean I don't I don't want to be playing
to the people who just hate Mexicans you
know and that's a and actually this I
this might be way too pie-in-the-sky but
an idea for how do you make inroads as
if so you guys are not Republicans but a
lot of the audience are right force
people say how the Republicans get back
to a majority how do you make inroads
into a minority population maybe if you
become more explicitly the party of
business owners you do that business
immigrants especially in small business
owner business owners immigrants are
much more likely to start a business
than native-born Americans and if you
own a business that's decently
successful you become something of a
neighborhood leader and so you become
the one who the you know the Korean
grocer and the Salvadoran restaurant
owner if they become out there and they
are explicitly they clearly see that the
Republican Party and the free market
movement and the libertarian movement is
on their side then they can become
community leaders who then can bring
people around it well don't don't the
Republicans I mean one of the things
that strikes me as odd as their eyes
like how do we win the Latino vote in
all of this and it's like between george
w bush and rick perry they have two
models of a major stay with a very heavy
Latino population who are getting forty
percent or more and running and I think
you know first is that unlike you know
we I think everybody including Mitt
Romney's most of his sons would agree he
was the worst candidate ever but you
don't talk about deporting people
immediately you might learn how to speak
spanish you might you know be willing to
shake hands with hispanics you know it
doesn't seem that complicated and you
create a world in which they can kind of
get along and work and you know and live
I think you're completely right on that
front and just that my father is Puerto
Rican I my perspective on this is simply
that the Republican Party for years has
been sending they they have no cultural
awareness to the degree that they will
send Cubans to try to sell free-market
ideas to Mexicans and not understand
what they're doing wrong and there is
something just sort of about that basic
understanding but I I think that there
is something sort of more meaningful
going on here too in the sense that
this this immigration conversation is an
important one but think about again how
the immigration process started it
started with the stakeholders around a
table and the stakeholders were the bigs
they were the unions they were the big
businesses that is who this policy was
formed to to have the feel like it's
please that's why you see the the elites
of the Republican Party right now saying
we're gonna spend a slew of money to
slam this thing through it's never about
what's actually good for the middle and
lower class for the small business owner
etc it's not the right priorities in
terms of you were looking to I think
it's also it's fascinating because
George Bush actually I mean essentially
everything that's being talked about now
Bush had pushed earlier in 2005 or 2006
what was different there was that the
unions were not involved at all and now
the SEIU in particular is kind of
flipped and is willing to talk about
comprehensive immigration exactly
exactly well let's let's talk about and
we'll get two questions in a few minutes
but let's talk about the prospects of
this the Republican Party and you know
first we'll talk about this how this is
playing out in the Republican Party and
then we'll ask a question which I think
Jesse will lead on as to whether or not
it's not whether or not this is a good
strategy for the Republicans to win the
White House but the real question at
least for most reason I think readers
and and certainly staffers is can the
GOP actually be libertarian in any way
shape or form but there is clearly a
pushback against this kind of
libertarianism when you look at people
like Justin Amash when you look at
people like Rand Paul they are as they
rise in profile they're being attacked
by establishment candidates is this
something that the Republican Party
which needs some kind of reboot are they
willing to actually kind of channel
their inner libertarian or their inner
populace yes so the way you win in
politics is not by convincing people in
power to agree with you but by
convincing them that it's in their
interest to act like they agree with you
and when Rand Paul went on that floor
and the magic of Twitter and Facebook
and emails and phone calls all of a
sudden every Republican senator needed
to realize that they need to pretend
like they agreed with Rand Paul oh and
when you see Mitch McConnell kind of
float up into a filibuster about drone
strikes you know something
yeah and Mitch Mitch McConnell voted
against the farm bill in the Senate
Mitch McConnell and leadership voted
against reauthorizing the export-import
bank of the United States and so there
is this certainly this idea among the
leadership where they feel pressure from
the libertarian populism frankly that's
going on so I think it has it does
certainly have promised i think that the
promise that i see here is that the
primary pushback is coming from I mean I
worked with with mike garson and Pete
Wehner in the bush white house in the
speechwriting office I disagreed with
them then and I disagree with them even
more vehemently now they're essentially
trying to sell a warmed-over version of
compassionate conservatism as the way
forward I would argue that 2004 is not a
replicable event without the threat
outside without the need to have that
bat signal up in the sky that says we
need a cold-hearted Republican to come
in and brutalize some terrorists there's
they're not going to be able to actually
proceed along these lines and I think
that frankly this is this is something
that we're putting out to the
marketplace to test you know if this if
this really is going to work if it's
going to be the way forward then I think
you're going to see more and more people
cling to it Jesse let me ask you this in
terms of broadening from just the
discussion of Republicans you know chris
christie when he attacked rand paul
recently said you know there's this
dangerous libertarian strain coursing
through both parties when you look at
people like glenn greenwald who as you
know really brought a national security
questions to bear also had written a
drug policy a drug decriminalization
study for the Cato Institute does this
also have the ability to you think to
reach across to independence or
left-leaning Democrats or kind of sick
of the Democratic Party well I I think
an even better thing to look at is you
know who voted for the Amash proposal I
mean that cut both on both sides it
through both parties and I have even
less hope of the Democratic Party
turning towards libertarian populism
than i do of the Republican Party which
is just about no I think you'd have to
go back to the 70s to see like a bunch
of Democrats actually seriously engaging
this idea when people like Fred Harris
talked about abolishing the ICC I mean
those days are long past us but I think
in general you don't want to put all
your eggs in one basket you want to have
left right alliances you want to find
ways to both reach out to the people who
feel like they're natural
publicans because they believe in free
enterprise but they start to realize
that they sort of corporatist cozy
arrangement is not the same as free
competition and on the flip side there
people on the Left who disliked being
pushed around by large institutions and
our I mean they could um let me think
about the bizarre health insurance
situation we have in this country where
a whole bunch of regulations and tax
incentives both because of them all this
health care spending not only gets
channeled through health insurance but
then you're almost guaranteed to have to
get your health insurance through your
job and think about the ways that makes
people afraid to leave their jobs and
more at the mercy of their bosses god
forbid they want to go start their own
business and self-insure if you can beat
this is the sort of concerns that people
on the Left have and these are the sorts
of concerns that there's actually a very
large libertarian literature for how to
deal with so like Obamacare which
promises to say you know what you can go
get healthy well you know what what what
you wind up what you wind up having I
mean what you wind up having is a
liberalism that says we're not really
going to break down these big
institutions but we'll help you afford
to deal with them and we're not going to
get rid of these things that raise the
cost of living but if you jump through
the right amount of Hoops will give you
some subsidies and I think that's a
really stunted vision of populism that
we could outdo their vision is one of
regulation and of subsidy it's very
similar to the technocratic Republican
vision I think libertarian populism
would offer something that is different
from both of those and that would give
those people an answer to their problem
I think along the lines of what you've
diagnosed that is that is different and
that is that is new and that I actually
think that will have some appeal and I
can't see the Democratic Party actually
moving away from the corporatism they
have I mean Obama's probably less
corporatists and whoever the Democratic
nominee and Obama's pretty Corbett is I
wrote a book about it right there um and
Hillary would be much more corporate as
Marty O'Malley as a governor has been I
mean maybe there's a russ feingold out
there in the Democratic Party who would
be an anti-corporate is with some
libertarian streak in them but I don't
see I think there's actually more
flexibility for Republican
to move away from corporatism than for
democrats and move away is there any
possibility i guess be shortly before
they both left office Ron Paul and
Barney Frank you know pushed legislation
to legalize marijuana or get rid of
federal prohibition on marijuana is that
you know are those viable opportunities
you know somebody like Rand Paul and he
got Mitch McConnell to sign on to
legalizing industrial hemp in Kentucky
and what not are those how much do those
kinds of issues which aren't as big
ticket as foreign policy or you know
entitlements does that matter in any of
this I think it does matter to degree
and I think that you'll see it at the
state level within the next couple of
years Texas could easily legalize pot
and I think that one of the things that
will see you know over the course of of
this conversation is that there's going
to be some surprising conversations that
happen in normally considered sort of
conservative states that have since
become more interested in individual
liberty in areas like that Jesse and I
guess let's have a quick run through
move from Jesse towards me you know do
you think that the Republican Party is
the natural vehicle for this kind of
libertarian populism and will they
actually you know will they bring at
least a candidate to the finish line to
for an up-or-down vote from Americans no
i don't i think there's a nation there
that some people like that people like a
mosh are creating for
libertarian-leaning republicans i agree
with what Tim said that you know it's
more important to build a movement that
can pressure people who don't agree with
you than to elect people who agree with
you but at the moment I feel like we're
mostly what we'll get out of them is lip
service I'd like to build this to the
point where we can get more than we've
gotten so far I mean showing up at a
filibuster is great but you know that
hasn't stopped any drone strikes I agree
with you that it's difficult to make
that prediction right now but my
position is simply that they're going to
have to change in order to survive and
that and that because of that the the
push to individualism the different
priorities that people are going to have
is going to push more and more people in
that direction so you may not get a
nominee out of it but I think you'll end
up with a pretty sizable faction the
ugly truth is a libertarian populism
movement would need to find a big donor
class it's different from the current
donor class of K Street in the business
packs and there's some of that the club
for growth freedomworks those guys all
get
money is it enough to run a presidential
race and would the current donor class
then get on board with a more
libertarian party if it looked like they
were going to take over the GOP yeah
okay well thank you thanks for your
comments guys let's start some questions
and we'll start with Terry Michael the
one of maybe three libertarian Democrats
six Democrats okay so please give your
question and then all agree articulate
it yeah what okay thank you by the way
when i left my house on capitol hill I
ran into ross tooth out pushing his baby
in a stroller I tried to get together to
ditch the kid and come here but it did
not worry um he was bullying daddy duty
for the last seven years I've been
trying thanks to Nick and reason to
insinuate libertarian ideas into the
Democratic Party people say i'm selling
at windmills have lost a lot of friends
what do you mean a Democrat and a
libertarian but i still have I used to
be press secretary for the dnc back in
the dark ages in the 80s so I still have
a view that we got to make public policy
through these two imperfect instruments
and I'm all for the independence to try
to tweak that message but it seems to me
that I get a lot better chance of
getting libertarian ideas in the
Democratic Party than you do the
Republican Party if that's your motive
and here's why it's government this is
the iteration of the Cato thing out of
my bank account away from my body out of
the bedroom then the hell out of Baghdad
and the rest of the backyards of the
rest of the world Democrats in the
electorate except those last three
things not the Dupont Circle afl-cio
wing of the Democratic Party because
they're as war profiteering as you can
get but I understand it's really hard to
get the Nancy Pelosi's of the world
reactionary left liberals on economics
to fit into that point but on the other
hand in Republican Party you have the
neocon nut still grabbing the party by
the scrotum you have the militarist
based Republican Party in the south
still with its radical social cultural
conservatism
and you got lip service to free markets
well so tell me your motive here I no
motive is to instead do I Democratic
Party a libertarian ideas first first I
look at polls about you know Liberal
Democrats and drone strikes and that
sort of thing and I think you'll see the
voting populace is not that libertarian
on foreign policy the yeah no no I that
you know I think even even even the
electorate but then also because I did I
didn't address your earlier comment
about abortion I'll take this come
libertarian is in an anarchist a
libertarian believes that if the
government has a proper role it's to
defend the vulnerable against violence
and a baby inside a womb is about as
vulnerable as they get an abortion is an
act of violence so I know that not
everybody in this room agrees with this
I know that you probably think Ron Paul
was one of your favorite members of the
House Rand Paul one of your favorite
members of the Senate pro-life can fit
firmly in a libertarian movement I agree
that a lot of Christian conservatives go
too far and become status but I think
that that's rolling back especially as
they see that the the fight for over the
cultural issues is a fight for religious
liberty by Christians who want it to not
be illegal to live as Christian
conservatives and just to give a little
bit of skepticism I mean Ron Wyden is
obviously somebody who agrees with a lot
of I think things from Tim and a lot of
people in this room when it comes to
skepticism of the power of government
and and how much its invaded people's
privacy and yet on health care issues
you know I view him as somebody who I
could never work with on those and so I
think their problems in terms of
applying both things I agree with the
with Tim statement about the pro-life
issue generally well I think the you
know these alliances have to be modular
you know I mean I'm delighted to work
with Ron Wyden where I mean I'm not
working with them I'm glad to I'm glad
to have my proxies working with him in
the areas where it makes sense and
denied and the same applies to you know
Ron to Rand Paul you know I don't agree
with about everything you know hi Jon
Glaser antiwar.com I have two quick
questions the first one is I'm a little
confused us why we need a new name for
this just sounds doesn't sound like
libertarian populism whatever you your
interpretation of those two words are
just sounds like libertarians and I
think libertarians would do well
especially you know people who like
reason and like Cato to call it what it
is and which and what it's always been
which is libertarianism the second quick
question is if this to the extent that
this represents an actual shift what do
you think was the trigger you know was
it the excesses of bush or the excesses
of Obama or was it purely the economic
crisis or was it post 9-11 policies and
so forth I'll answer the first half of
that question very quickly the what's
the iron Rand SI the virtue of greed
virtue of selfishness yeah so and I had
friends who drove around there gulp
mobile back when we were all Randy ins
with dollar bills waving from the
antennas that a lot of libertarianism
the emphasis and the rhetoric has
focused on you know millionaires are
awesome let them keep doing it and some
of it is just a rhetoric but not just
that but it also is pairing it with some
of a moral understanding that we do in
fact there is a moral obligation to you
know look out for and care for the poor
the government shouldn't be doing it but
saying you know we need to limit the
role of government we need to make sure
that society isn't you know screwing
over the the people who are worse off
that some of the the emphasis some of
the things you engage in outside of
politics is going to change compared to
what and there's nothing hopefully
unliberated about it that's why I can
beat libertarian populism it's a strain
of it but it's refocusing its energies
the trigger is the consequence of the
Bush years its 2006 to 2009 and the
lessons that limited government
conservatives took from that in the
sense of mismanagement of not just two
wars but Katrina losing the status of
the Republican Party as the adult in the
room I think that a lot of that prompted
them to sort of look seriously at what
they had been considering before is
already as well yeah let me throw in two
more ideas is that first of all it when
you say libertarian populism delivered
is modifying populism it's saying this
is a libertarian approach to breaking up
concentrated power I think the phrase
makes sense and on that level and also i
mean just beyond I mean I I never went
through a Rand face I never had a golf
mobile but I mean that there is this
sort of you could never afford one I
never care oh yeah and I drove it into a
goal to anyway so but I there's this
there is this sort of strain of what you
might call sort of a frat boy
libertarianism which is like you know
they want to have the right to party
they want to have the keep the money to
party with and you know I'm party on
dude you know it's whatever but it at
the same time you know there's a they
haven't actually thought much about what
other people what freedoms other people
are missing and what the sort of
institutional environment that the state
has created is and I think some
libertarians could afford to have at
whether libertarian populism is the best
label for you know that sort of
refocusing is that is up in the air I
mean like I didn't coin the work but I
think that that is something but I mean
it in that sort of focusing
libertarianism so does stay
libertarianism that means don't
forgetting that not forgetting this
populist dirt or whatever you want to
call it side of it you know if I can add
to that too I mean I think it's
certainly a treason and I I'm sure a
Cato and other freemarker groups its
libertarianism that we're interested in
and so the idea of a populism that's
participating in that rhetoric is good
but you know more broadly in the country
i think the the you know a undeniable
continuity between the bush years and
the Obama years the policies whether it
was tarp the bailouts you know stimulus
which started under bush and then
continued under obama national
surveillance war foreign policy it's
like holy cow this is you know really it
is us little guys against them the the
power elites and that that's helped to
refocus the debate in a positive way
let's have a question back here and then
we'll come up okay please identify
yourself and hi Laurie Sanders with our
street haibin hi tum hi Jesse so
question I think that likes what I
obviously think this stuff is great
but it also seems to me to be an
overwhelmingly male narrative and it's
room seems to be overwhelmingly male
know it's a narrative that I agree with
I'm here I would work in the libertarian
movement but i'm curious your thoughts
other than education policy where I do
think you have a clear win with women
against teachers unions against the type
of bureaucracy you deal with with your
child going to school other than with
education how does this narrative of you
know I'm fighting back against the man
who's holding me down it doesn't really
appeal to me as a woman I have great
news for you on that front and that's
that I acknowledge that problem i
actually have started a libertarian
populist woman's google group we have
about 30 women on it and i see a problem
with this right away and and among them
you include professional women women of
various experience in terms of age and
childbirth and everything along those
lines around the idea of tailoring
policies to meet that within that I
think we have particularly focused on
the rise of working women particularly
the return of working moms to the
workforce in the wake of wage stagnation
and how much of a regulatory burden is
put on them not just through the tax
code in terms of taxing them at their at
their spouses level and taking more out
of their out of that but also on the
health insurance front on the childcare
front where you can't actually exempt
more than 3,000 and childcare expenses
which nowhere close to what most of them
need and so there's a host of different
issues that are within that set but it's
a problem that I think I'm already well
aware of and I think a lot of the rest
of my wife wishes that being taxed at my
level was more of a problem than it is
but she also wishes she's a stay-at-home
mom and she wishes that neighbor kids
her babysitting them for pay did not
involve dealing with Marty O'Malley and
with the IRS in the insane ways that it
does there are lots of ways in which the
entrepreneur the small business the
woman working from home baking cakes
Rick Perry thankfully repeal the bill in
Texas that basically it had been the the
baking companies had said we don't want
people to be able to sell cakes a baked
from their house now maybe I'm the worst
sexist in the world from playing that
women bake more cakes from their house
but I bet if you look at it
statistically they do women are more
like that in patient
eldred peerless law yes listen let me
let me give one more example during
during the conversation about birth
control during the last election I had a
back and forth with some of these more
socially conservative women who disliked
something that I had said about about
essentially that you should have that
the way to get rid of this problem is to
make all birth control be available
over-the-counter just like you would
purchase aspirin nobody thinks that it
should be free but you do want to have
access and it's a pushback against what
Obama was proposing a lot of the social
conservatives at the time we're pushing
back against me but I warned them in the
wake of this election they're going to
make plan be available over the over the
counter for everybody and sure enough
now we're coming back and having this
conversation again Jindal is endorsed
you know putting it all over the counter
that's a libertarian populist solution
you the employer shouldn't have to pay
for it you you should have to bet you
should have to pay for it but you should
be able to get it because it's
everywhere yeah you don't need the
intermediary and the doctor and big
farms etc yeah Fred Smith a little push
back here I'm from Louisiana as I've had
experience with populism and yes indeed
populism is wonderful at breaking up the
big corporate monoliths it destroyed
every industry in Louisiana bankrupt the
states but it didn't drive the welfare
state out and it's now our corrupts it's
a banana republic with a bananas okay it
seems to me that interest politics is
about interest groups and to write off
bigness per se you haven't written off
the big Democratic Party of the big
Republican Party but you've immediately
seemingly written off big business it
seems to me that the politics is a
baptism bootlegger the ideological
interest groups and the economic
interest groups and we certainly worry
about the use that the economic interest
groups are now playing in politics but
isn't there a if we're willing to
proselytize the Democrats and the
Republicans should we proselytize
elements of the business community try
to find them those who are benefited by
economic liberalization and find a
counter strategy because the right off
economic groups leave you with
ideological groups and as far as I know
Hitler Pol Pot mausi tongue and Stalin
did not do it for the money a lot of a
lot of
you know populism is often used by the
Liberals I'll use another term used by
liberal solidarity business solidarity
will drive us towards libertarianism
when the businesses are going out
lobbying for their own narrow
self-interest they often are pushing for
the regulations in the subsidies this is
why the chamber in I think frankly a
majority of what the Chamber of Commerce
lobbies for ends up being free markets
because there's no regulation that
broadly benefits the whole market even
if a broadly benefits DuPont or whatever
it doesn't broadly benefit the whole
market they did back the bailouts didn't
they yeah elation the chamber has always
been on our side when it comes to
spending and corporate welfare the
chamber is often on the big government
side but that's why I think sort of yeah
the US us Baptists up on the saves need
to sort of make sure these guys say
let's have solidarity between this and
when we're fighting against
anti-regulation we're also going to
fight against the bailouts and for free
markets and I think a lot of the
businesses can be won over and I'll even
some of the business lobbies can be won
over but right now they go out there and
they say look it's the Republicans and
Democrats are both just handing out
favors so why are we going to take some
principle sin instead of just getting
our favors from both parties where it's
your fault where for the libertarian
populace on the Dyess where where do you
stand on the internet sales tax is that
you know is it the is it good for the
little guy that you don't have to pay
sales tax or is it bad for the local
small business owner it's really it's a
really tricky tricky question because a
question of fairness I think ought to be
part of a free market libertarian
economic policy for me it was just so
telling how it was a stalemate while it
was walmart versus amazon and then once
amazon joined walmart then the tax
passed so i mostly use it as a tale in
this is how policy gets made as far as
what the correct policy is it's another
one where one origin base or I mean I
think that I think that you have to sort
of say people who benefit from this or
the ones who are actually you know
you're living in a neighborhood you're
selling in that neighborhood that's the
way that we ought to have
you know sort of a fair tax policy and I
think that you know the the NZ approach
is exactly wrong from that perspective
in terms of favoring the bigs here also
following up on taxes because you know
part of the libertarian populist
platform seems to be a flat tax and
certainly simplifying the tax code but
then you get a sale by kind of big you
know establishment Republicans saying
okay well that's the biggest write-off
for wealthy people how do you respond to
those kinds of questions well okay so i
don't think a flat tax needs to be the
priority i think if you even if you have
a flat tax once you have an exemption if
you think about it it's progressive
because it's fifteen percent on every
dollar above the exemption or whatever
percentage so the idea of a progressive
rate is something that almost anybody if
you buy into an income tax with an
exemption you're buying into a
progressive rate and I definitely think
you have to buy into the exemption the
stupidest argument Republicans layout is
that you need to be taxed on the first
dollar sort of the michelle bachman
argument that it's a crime that there
are people who aren't paying income tax
so a big juicy exerts there's a crime
it's a crime that people aren't avoiding
and yes so a giant juicy exemption and
then if the rates are progressive that
doesn't bother me and that's another
example of shifting the priorities what
bothers me is a complexity which rigs a
game in favor of the people who can
afford to hire the former chief of staff
to the Ways and Means Committee John
Wharton when I heard the the topic of
today's discussion I had a little alarm
bell go off in me and you you mentioned
why this name is Huey Long when we talk
about populism the temptation is always
that someone is going to rise up like
Huey Long or like Barack Obama and say
you can trust me because I'm a friend of
the little guy and then of course we
come to realize that all he's doing is
building his power base with those who
are less sophisticated as to the kinds
of manipulations that that real
political professionals know how to do
very well and get funded by the big boys
on K Street so what I is a libertarian
I'm looking for is the kind of leader
who would actually build in his own
self-destruction along the lines of a
Tom Coburn whom I think is a great guy
and I'd like to see more politicians
like him who has I believe restricted
himself and I think he's going
be good to his word to up to terms
against gone and he will not extend them
my concern is that Iran Paul will just
be building another sort of power base
another layer of sophistication another
game to play on the American people so
how how is libertarian populism any
different how can we protect against
this how can we maintain the ideals of
small government I I just want to throw
out the idea again that movement
building is more important than you know
finding the right politician to back I
mean having a having the ability to
pressure politicians and not putting all
your eggs in the basket of Huey Long or
Earl wrong long or alfalfa Bill Murray
or whichever whichever populist
politician you're thinking of yeah and I
would just add to that I think I think
the centerpiece of this is making the
argument that a libertarian free market
answer to these problems actually does
favor the little guy in a way that the
existing superstructure of liberalism's
game-playing when it comes to the
subsidization side or the republicans
sort of technocratic we can do the life
of julia except a little bit cheaper and
a little bit more efficiently which is
just not from my perspective a long-term
viable alternative let's have one more
question yeah Steve Allen capital
Research Center at the risk of sounding
like the geezer who walked three miles
to school in the snow and and so forth I
would point out that the people have
thought about this before and I worked
in the Reagan campaign in 76 and we had
brochures that were attacking big
business big labor and big government
and that was that was the formula that
we used and then after Reagan lost the
nomination a lot of people came back and
there was a group called the libertarian
republican alliance where i was on the
advisory board with the physician named
ron paul and so there were a lot of
people talk about this in fact Richard
Vickery and I brought a copies in case
it nobody believed me Richard big
gorilla glue wrote a piece for The
Washington Post attacking Reagan for not
going far enough in this direction 1983
America's ruling class has got to go we
were talking about earlier about the
sugar issues that's Reagan Reagan signed
that exactly so so I guess my question
is do you think the stars have sort of
aligned now with everything from the big
bank bailout to the mess and foreign
policy to give an opera
unity to libertarian populism that maybe
didn't exist in recent years first of
all if this were a new idea that would
be the surest guarantee that it was
wrong as Nick said I'm a conservative
and so but yes the the stars have kind
of aligned the the bailout okay I wrote
a book in 2006 the big rip off which is
actually better than the book I wrote in
2009 but nobody bought it because nobody
under like I'd have TV host being like
wait are you the conservative or the
liberal and then after 2008 everybody
realized that Bay allows Obama got more
money from Goldman Sachs and any other
company ever did Obamacare was his
corporate is love fest the stimulus etc
and so 2010 was the the the real point
where the stars were most aligned then
the republicans nominated Mitt Romney
the fact that that was a failure mean
set it's possible that they will realign
I mean some of what my job is is
predicting the future of politics and I
do think that the things can possibly
line up now and whether they will or not
I'd say less than fifty percent but
better than previously I I'm not sure
that the stars have aligned but I do
think that it it's more promising now
than it was then in a sense because I
think people have seen the lessons of
failure from the other side and I think
that that's the lesson both of leftist
failure and of rightist failure in terms
of this approach to governance and I
think that people are frankly right for
something new they want to have hopes in
something new and I think this does have
a sort of nuna student in the sense that
it hasn't been tried yet to the degree
that you were sort of working on up to
that stage or that we're talking about
now Jesse do you want to do you have
anything I'm not an astrologer I don't
know if the stars are aligned or not
talk a little bit though possibly about
you know drawing from kind of past
experiences is there a generational
shift because you know one of the things
that's interesting is a couple of months
ago I guess at this point the college
republican national committee sponsored
a study a survey of millennials 18 to 29
year old voters and one of the questions
they ask these people was named the next
generation of leaders in the Republican
Party and in the Democrat
party who are the future leaders and in
the Republican Party that we're talking
about people like Ted Cruz Marco Rubio
nikki Haley Rand Paul Justin Amash
susana Martinez I mean there were a
number of people who were under the age
of 60 there when it came to the
Democrats that were like well there's
Hillary Clinton maybe Cory Booker are
their shifts at American politics where
it's actually more age-based and kind of
generational and that maybe this is what
we're seeing is that Obama even though
he's relatively young as a president is
the end of an era of a post-war era that
really did celebrate bigness and we're
now moving into a kind of trans partisan
phase towards a kind of populist
understanding you know when I start when
I became sort of libertarian in the late
80s there was this whole big thing about
how the boomers were the new libertarian
generation and then in the 90s I
remember USA Today doing a big story now
Generation X was the libertarian
generation you know and now apparently
the Millennials are going to be the
libertarian generation and the positive
spin is maybe the world is just getting
more libertarian and each generation
makes the old generation look like a
bunch of fogies but I get really
skeptical about these generational
generalizations I will say this that if
you look at serve the periods when
there's a sort of burst of individualism
and challenges too entrenched
institutional power of all kinds big
government and others they tend to fall
at least in the last century into to
sort of categories there's the period
like the 20s and the 90s where it's
between crises people turn inward
there's not a big war or a depression
that can give people an excuse for
assembling power and as a result there's
this sort of decadent flowering of
individualism right and nine-time
decadent I don't just mean in the sort
of counter cultural way I just mean in
the sense that you can't be sort of
brought into these big projects the
other is times like the 1970s and now
when there's just so many crushing
failures of institutional power that
you're in the midst of the crisis and
everything has failed I mean this whole
sort of the series of Iraq Katrina the
2008 collapse I mean one after another
and then Obama doing the same stuff that
Bush did
that opens up a different sort of space
which i think is a lot bleecker and it
opens up space for other things besides
libertarianism as well I think we've all
seen this but it's um that sort of
opportunity is on our plate right now it
also could turn out to be something
along the lines of the 1830s where you
have the breakdown of these vast
institutions but in a surprising sort of
flowering in response to that of
healthier communities that actually can
work together hey guess what maybe we
don't need to have these overarching big
institutions in order to hold things
together maybe we can take care of
ourselves and so I think that's kind of
the optimism behind it okay well we will
leave it there for today I want to thank
Jesse Walker of Reason Ben Domenech of
the transom and of real clear politics
and of Heartland Institute Tim Carney
the washington examiner in several books
one of which is much better than the
other so go back to your Amazon and get
that and I'm nickel SP for reason and
reason TV thanks all for coming
you